all right before we get to that let's
have a quick look at our
answers to our review questions so i was
looking for a value of
a and a value of b i guess we should
also call these the
real and the imaginary parts components
of
this this quotient that we've got here
i'm actually less interested in the
numbers i'm more interested in
how we get there where do these numbers
come from what's the process that you go
through to get from there
to here can you take us yeah go ahead
morgan so
um first because of the division yeah we
have to do
uh conjugate so we make the bottom as so
we do combine square for the uh not
completely square you you do the
difference between square footage
and your times the conjugate on the top
so and then
at the bottom you're going to get 17 yep
where fraction 17 come from
and on top you just do multiplication
excellent i think
that's perfect um and i think we're
reasonably comfortable i think morgan
outlined it really nicely if we were to
generalize exactly what he just said
if you had some question right we have
notation to
to sort of condense everything that
morgan just said
we multiply by the conjugate what's our
notation for that it would be
w with a bar over the top right a dash
so it'd be w bar but of course you can't
just multiply the bottom you're also
going to multiply the top
but that'll deal with because of
difference of squares w times
w bar w times w bar what happens when
you actually do this the difference of
squares means
you're going to get from this does
anyone remember proving
this result here what do you don't just
get like 17 is not just some
coincidental number
what relationship does it have to the
denominator can you see
four squared plus one squared when do we
calculate what thing do we try and do
when we're squaring the two parts it's
when we're working out the
scenario starts with an m the modulus
right
so in fact what you get from the bottom
here is the modulus of w
squared same deal right does that make
sense so in fact you can sort of
now we're starting to get familiar with
why this happens you can sort of go
directly there
are you happy with these solutions
thumbs up fantastic
let's have a look at this so i asked you
to go from it's in polar form here i
gave you because i was nice i gave you a
an exact angle
two pi on three in both cases and then
the uh the modulus is three
have you look at this right um before i
even look at the numbers i'm just gonna
do a sense check what quadrant
is this complex number in
the second quadrant right which which
should make sense because you're going
negative horizontally up vertically that
should make sense because 2 pi on 3 if
you start from
the positive side of the real axis and
then you wind around 2.3 radians
of course you should be in the second
quadrant right and are you happy with
those numbers
check it out excellent and then last one
here you sort of go through the same
process
really finding a modulus
and an argument we just write it in a
different form and again what i would
encourage you to do
if not mentally just like on the page
one take away i is down here
right so here's the number i'm going to
you can use pythagoras to work out what
this modulus is
checks out and then we've got uh minus i
4 that's that looks good to me because
negative pi 4 is the direction i go in
happy times excellent so
in those starter questions you saw we
have these three forms
for complex numbers right we've got
rectangular or cartesian form
we've got polar or trigonometric form
mod arg form so many names
sorry and then lastly most recently
we've been learning about
exponential form okay now the question
you should be asking yourself is
why why why so many forms why not just
have
one form and i've got at least two
reasons for you the second one i'm going
to explore
mostly today here comes the first reason
we've been doing this for a while taking
numbers and then representing them in
multiple forms so
this is not a trick question right if
that rectangle up the top
is one just in the quad in your mind in
fact i'm gonna ask you to pick up your
pen
and on your page i'd like you to tell me
how would you write oh the shading is
not the brightest but i hope you can see
there's some shaded stuff there right
can you see the parts that are shaded
and pass it on okay
there's a bunch of ways to numerically
represent or symbolically represent this
picture
right can you go ahead and on your page
write one
or two or more i can think of quite a
few
how would you write or say to someone
what number that is let me just give you
a moment to do that i'm just going to
have a quick wander around
and see what you write yeah i'll admit
there's some ambiguity here so many many
different solutions
are available here um i did mean right
if this
guy is one then this will also be one
and then this is
more than that right so who wrote a
fraction as
their number okay smart what did you
write
seven over four who else had 704
okay fantastic did anyone else write
something different yeah go ahead again
one and three quarters so we would call
these by the way we have names for these
right
in year seven and eight right or maybe a
bit earlier we would have called this
guy
an improper fraction and this guy a
mixed euro i've still got more to go i
hope you do too but before we get there
like why would i want this one for
example over this one
is there any reason why you might think
this might be in some situations more
useful than this
yeah what do you think jeff when you are
rounding up around your
whole number solution yeah fantastic
right if i'm like oh
this is supposed to be i'm like modeling
some situation maybe there's going to be
a population of some kind and then i get
this as an answer
and then i'm like well it's a model so
it's approximate what's that closest to
like
i don't i don't know but now i can say
oh it's close to two right well maybe if
i was graphing it and i know what's
going on
so you can already see even just between
these two forms they're suited to
different purposes what else did we have
calvin i think you put your hand up what
was the different form you had
1.75 right which i suppose in this
scheme is closest to the mixed numeral
but it's different again we're in we're
in decimal land right and then if you
want to go further in there i can think
of at least one more easy one that
is the same as all these numbers if you
were thinking perhaps
aha okay so if you're like starting from
something and then explaining oh this
thing is growing it's getting bigger
we generally say like our gdp has
increased by 175 percent well it hasn't
this year anyway
right it's like wow okay what happened
we we discovered oil or something okay
now
all of these four forms right and this
is my point they each have
different purposes um things that are
useful for so the word we would use for
this is utility
right they are useful for different
things and it is exactly the same
it is exactly the same with the
different forms of complex numbers
rectangular form polar form exponential
form they're useful
in different situations and in fact we
keep doing this right i'm going to sort
of a bit of a spoiler right but when we
get to it
a part of the extension two course that
is called mechanics
uh you're going to learn about this now
if you're not a physics student like i
wasn't right
this is kind of like i vague i vaguely
have a sense of what acceleration
is i know like what it feels like but it
tends to be the maths of it
very unfamiliar we're not going to learn
one or two or three or four ways of
writing this you're going to learn
six why so many answer you saw different
purposes okay
now the second thing which we're going
to explore a little more um
is best explained by this picture
i don't know if how many of you've seen
this picture before right it's one of my
favorite pictures
um the whole idea here is if you only
see something from one angle
you might draw a particular conclusion
about what it was
right but seeing it from more angles
gives you insight
and understanding and that's my i mean
it's not just because i like to
alliterate
anyone who watched the video from this
week will know that but um it's
convenient right
you can understand something better when
you look at it from multiple
perspectives okay and uh that's what
we're actually going to have a look at
today lead space for a subheading
we'll fill it in in a second but what i
want to do is consider
if you have you know some arbitrary
complex number
i want to consider what happens when we
raise that complex number to some
arbitrary power m any power that you
like
okay now we've got three forms so we can
explore this
in three different ways we can look at
it from three different
perspectives so what i'd like us to do
is first let's think about rectangular
because that's the form that we began
with right
we would normally say that z in
rectangular form would be like you know
a plus i b right a plus i b so
z to the power of n in from a
rectangular point of view
would be a plus i b to the power of m
right uh what do we call this by the way
this this thing in here
because you've just done a topic in
extension one this is a binomial isn't
it right it's a
it's a term with two parts to it right
now the only problem with this is
because we don't know what n
is i can't like go to a particular row
and pascal's triangle be like oh it's
one four six four one or something like
that right who knows which row i'm up to
so therefore we're kind of stuck with
doing this in very
general terms now i promise we're only
going to do one line of this because
you'll start to realize why we don't
want to go any further
but what would be the first term in this
expansion right
okay so you're going to have to use your
binomial coefficients right i'm going to
write it like so there's my nc0
and then what okay i'm going to have
some number of a's and some number of
ibs the first term i'm going to have
lots of a's
and no ibs yeah is that ringing bell and
then you
move a term along so you'd be like oh
the next one's nc one
yeah i'll have one fewer a
and i'll have one extra ib right does
that make sense
and then this this just kind of keeps
going right you're gonna go
uh one less of these
two of these and then i'm going to keep
going right what will be my final term
okay ncn and then yeah i'll be
no no more a's they're all gone and
it'll be i to the power of
n b to the power of n is that okay
so you look at that and you think okay
it's true
but it looks kind of gross so it turns
out that this particular form
rectangular form
not so useful for trying to like it's
not a good form
to try and understand powers of a
complex number
right so now let's think about our other
two forms
okay let's go to polar and exponential
form
now what i'm going to do is briefly
pause and show you
this is what we did for rectangular i
just stated any old complex number
and raise it to a power you know what
the polar form of a complex number
looks like it's going to be z equals by
definition what do we start with
we generally are r for the modulus and
then the full thing is cos theta
plus i sine theta agreed okay
and then for exponential form we would
say the same number is z equals
starts with the same r for the modulus
but then e
to the i theta can you go ahead and
raise both of them
to the power of n just simplify as far
as you can get it might not be
very far but see what you end up with
give you about 30 seconds to do that